all right bill
hi bill uh which grow up where are you
from originally i was born in chicago
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents growing up yeah i grew
up in a typical middle class
suburban home family how would you
describe your childhood
chaotic uh abusive
what kind of stuff went on uh
molestation
i was physically abused emotionally
abused
kind of every kind of abuse there could
be to a kid we were but
it was in the 60s and 70s so that was
just the norm we thought
this was from who my parents your
parents
yes both parents uh my father was
the physical and the emotional abuser my
mother sexually abused us and my
we had there was a babysitter that would
sexually abuse us
so there were other siblings that yes
went through this
and what kind of kid were you in high
school uh
kind of a loner trouble always in
trouble
always just trying to get out of
everything
and how did this uh affect your life as
you as you
got older well i never really picked up
on any of the social skills i needed to
to be like a functioning member of
society type thing
and as a result i grew up an old man
that's
still a loner still don't really like a
lot with society don't really trust a
lot of people
have you ever been married or yeah i was
married once
you have kids yes i have uh
two sons that i never get to see
and i have a daughter and a stepdaughter
that i
i'm a very active part in their life
and what what kind of effects does this
have on your life now today how old are
you today i'm 60.
off 58. and uh how
how has this childhood trauma affected
you now
um i've had a lot of treatment so i've
gotten to work through a lot of it
um does that help oh yeah absolutely um
therapy when i was uh after prison they
sent me to another
special prison for sex offenders for
what they termed long term indefinite
control care and treatment and i did
about eight years eight and a half years
of
really intensive treatment there how
often would that happen like
weekly daily daily probably six eight
hours a day
four or five days a week really yeah i
was i mean it was an in-house it was a
prison
yeah it was a prison that they sent us
to and
you either went through their treatment
program or you stayed there what kind of
things would you work on um everything
i mean everything's related to your
sexual offending so it was from
childhood all the way up to the present
day
and you know the things that you you've
you've experienced in the way that
shapes your thinking and the way you
make your decisions and your problem
solving skills and your conflict
resolution skills you're just starting
to work on all of that you work on your
arousal management
mostly it's getting into all the things
that
that contributed to bringing you to a
point where you committed a sexual crime
all the thinking errors and the
emotional inabilities and
and the just everything that was just
wrong about the way you handled things
um it was it was pretty intense i mean i
never wanted to be there but i'm i'm
absolutely glad i
i was there and i i got everything that
i could from there
and you feel like you're a
better safer member of society now
absolutely yeah
absolutely i've been out uh 12 years now
i got arrested once for
i didn't register properly but the
registration laws can be so confusing
sometimes
so i got a registration violation for
not a
not registering a temporary address
correctly
so they gave me five years of probation
for that i got lucky
i didn't have to go back to prison
because if i had gone back to prison i
probably would have had to go back to
the center
but does the the temptation exist still
no i've learned how to deal with all
that i've learned i've learned what
voids i was trying to fill what needs i
was trying to satisfy
um the sad thing is as as a human being
we're so sexual you know
our sexuality is so hardwired into who
and what we are
that to try to deal with you you end up
developing
some i mean i don't want to put a light
coat on it but you end up developing
what we call an appetite
a desire and some of those desires may
never go away
but you just have to learn how to
rearrange your life relive your life so
that you're not putting yourself in
situations where there are temptations
you know i haven't thought about
molesting a child
i haven't indulged in any of the the
deviant fantasies that i i've had prior
because i've learned how to address me
how to carry me
how to move myself forward instead of
living in the now i learned how to look
forward a little bit and not set myself
up where there could be a problem
it's like any other addiction a sexual
addiction is is like any other addiction
and you just you got to learn what it is
that you were trying to fill what void
it is what pain you were trying to cover
or what
what thought whatever it was you thought
you were missing or
whatever shortcomings you thought you
had to overcome you had to learn to
to live your life in such a way that
those decisions don't come back up
so may i ask what kind of offenses you
had
i have my first offense was in 1990 that
was for
attempted capital sexual battery which
is just a
legal term for i touched a less than 12
year old or a girl that was under the
age of 12
and then in 1996 i got charged with the
lewd and lascivious battery which is
letting a child under the age of 16
see my genitals
so those are my charges
and so therapy worked very well it
sounds like for you
absolutely when i went into therapy i
was absolutely a psychopath
there's a there's actually a test for
that the hair pclr test
and i scored psychopathy off the charts
a normal person is somewhere 12 to 18 i
scored in the 30s
but through the treatment and through
the work that i was able to do
got myself back down to a normal score
in the mid
teens low teens and
again it's just as a sex offender and i
think as a human being
we can't we can't cause harm to another
human being without giving ourselves
some kind of a justification some kind
of a permission
we have to convince ourselves in some
kind of way although it's irrational
that it's okay to do what we're doing
and
as a result of that you lose what they
call empathy you you're not able to
emotionally connect with other people
and that's what allows you to to harm
another human being well
learning how to reconnect with people at
an emotional level
was it was a long and hard trip it took
a lot of work and it was not
i can't say that any step of it was
pleasant but the end result was that
you know i'm one of the fortunate ones
that got to get plugged back into the
human
human society yeah are you are you
happier now much happier
i'm i'm i've gotten to a point where i
can put all the
the trauma and the mistrust and all the
stuff that happened to me is
as a child and as a young adult
i can put all that away and and just
live in the now
and i'm far happier with who i am the
direction i'm going
what i've become i've become a giver not
a taker
and i'm happy with that do you ever have
what emotions do you struggle with still
depression or anger or anxiety anything
like that
sometimes i struggle with anger um
depression not so much because
you know life is every life is what you
see
and i have there's so many things that
make me happy there's so many things
that i'm so happy are part of my life i
have a beautiful grandchildren
i have an amazing daughter and a
stepdaughter that are
just wonderful wonderful people so i i
tend to focus more on the
you know what's good instead of what's
wrong and then that keeps me in a
positive frame of mind
so i'm not i'm not looking to overcome
anything i'm just looking to enjoy it
how is your relationship with your
family been through all this with my
children or
my both uh my children are fine with my
parents i haven't
spoken my parents in decades what about
your siblings none of them
you don't talk to them no do you know if
your siblings are struggling with some
of the same stuff
i wouldn't know i had i mean i was
pretty young when i was kicked out of
the house and i've never turned back and
i don't have any interest
in it um it's i don't want to go back to
a situation where
you know through all the treatment i
went through i've learned to see not
just my shortcomings but things that
contributed to it and
you know a lot of it falls into the way
i was raised and the the
atmosphere i was raised in and i just
have no desire to go back to it
at all it sounds like you take a lot of
the responsibility for for what you did
i made my decisions nobody you know i
i'm not one of these ones that like say
oh my mommy took my pacifier away too
early so i turned out all screwed up now
that i did what i did
i made the decision i created the
problems i committed the actions
i did all that that was me nobody did
that it's nobody else's fault it's my
fault
um but that's a static thing you can't
undo that
all i can do is figure out why did i do
that what contributed to that
what what was what was the cocktail that
all the conditions were right to make
that happen and then make sure that
those conditions don't happen again
and so there's just no need for me i'm
i'm much happier without my family i
don't want to be
a part of their lives and as far as i
know they don't really want to be a part
of mine
what's the most important lesson do you
feel like you've learned my most
important lesson
um uh to be honest with myself
you know what you don't have to be
perfect everything doesn't have to feel
good you know sometimes there's just bad
feelings sometimes
things aren't perfect and that's okay
and i i
you try to hold yourself up to such a
standard of perfection that you can't
possibly meet
and as a result you end up trying to
nurse your emotional wounds of
falling short of who you think you're
supposed to be and i found some pretty
screwed up ways of doing that
it's almost like you re-parented
yourself after you started all this
therapy
i absolutely did i mean my this
the um the clinical staff at the
center was phenomenal
there's so many people there that are
just they're going to fake it till they
make it you know they're just going
through the motions so they can get out
the gate and i can't lie
i wanted to do the same thing i want to
get out of there but
i was never ever ever happy in my life
ever
even when i had everything that you
could want
i was never a happy person but when i
went to the center and i realized you
know what here's a chance to actually i
mean i'm here i'm not going anywhere
they're not letting me out and i have a
chance to actually work on some things
and and start digging into some things
and start looking at some things because
there's nobody left to blame i'm sitting
here in a cell by myself
there's nobody left to blame it on so
once they saw that i was willing to do
the work and i really wanted to make
some changes in my life they
went all out for me they are the people
at the
florida civil commitment center the
clinical staff are amazing people
they uh one example there's a doctor
there
i hadn't cried when i was a kid my
parents would beat us and to stop us
from crying there's actually a
physiological
you can swallow and stop yourself from
crying if you're ever crying
swallow you'll stop my parents used to
beat it into a swallow it swallow it
and so as a result i became absolutely
unable to cry
i could not cry well one of the doctors
in the arcadia would literally take me
personally to her office
one night every week and work on trying
just to get me to cry
and it took a long long time and when we
finally had a breakthrough and i finally
started crying
it was an ugly ugly ugly cry but
she did that on her own that wasn't part
of her curriculum that wasn't part of
her
her her job that wasn't part she just
did that because she saw a need that
would
benefit me you know a way to express
myself a way to release my emotions a
way to
to to handle that without having to
stuff it all in because
nothing's big enough to handle it all of
it it's if you keep stuffing things in
eventually it's going to blow up
would you consider yourself one of the
very few that's that's broken out of
this
behavior absolutely it does it's not
very common i assume
um not from a psychopathy no um the
sexual desires
it's it's like any other addiction it's
you know you
there's a lot of people that can that
have overcome it
that don't want to be sex offenders i
never met one sex offender and i've been
doing this for 30 years
i never met one sex offender that wanted
to be a sex offender
never met one sex offender that was
happy with what they were doing that
thought what they were doing was right i
mean everybody knows it's wrong
it was just done we couldn't stop
ourselves because it's an addiction
and just like any other addiction you're
going to put yourself in in temptation's
way and you're going to fold eventually
but as far as the whole learning how to
think and feel and all that yeah i don't
think there's a lot of people that come
back from
from from that what was the hardest part
for you
um accepting myself the way i am
accepting myself as imperfect because
you know i grew up in a household where
you had to be perfect there was there
was no room for error
there was you know you didn't bring home
anything but an a um
you just you just had everything had to
be just perfect
and so accepting myself as imperfect and
having problems and and
being able to accept that okay here's
something that needs to be taken care of
here's something that needs to be looked
at or addressed
that was really difficult because i just
want to put my blinders on and just go
through life i'm good
everything's good were drugs or alcohol
ever a part of your life absolutely
not alcohol i mean that's only on a
tolerance thing just because i can't
drink
i just don't have the tolerance for it
but drugs yeah absolutely
and did that play a part in the
instances that
you absolutely yeah absolutely
and what's what's what advice can you
give to anyone else who's struggling
with something
thoughts like this or desires like this
i would say talk to somebody
understand that um
it doesn't have to be the way it is you
can talk to somebody and you can figure
out
there's something behind what you're
what you're feeling there's something
behind what you're desiring
and um you're not gonna find it acting
out on those desires
that's just uh there's another level to
it yeah it's just it's just a band-aid
that you're gonna put on it behind it
all there's something that you're
missing there's something that you need
and talk to somebody that can help you
find out what that is
i think a lot of a huge part of the
whole sex offending cycle is the secrecy
it's such a burden to carry around it's
such a a load that you have to carry
with you that
you you're going to fold underneath it
and if you can if you could find
someplace that
you could talk to somebody and and let
all that out
and not carry it around with you
sadly our system isn't set up for that
there's very few places in this country
where you can go and say look this is
what i'm feeling
and not get into some problems
but find somebody that you can talk to
before you act out before you act on the
issues
um and unload it don't carry around with
you because
it's not going to go anywhere all it
takes is the introduction of some
rational thought
to understand how to handle it it's it's
not really
that difficult to handle once you're
willing to do it once you're willing to
be honest about it but
you know it's funny it's you hear
society talk about
the sex offenders the boogeyman the the
child molester the
the bush jumpers whatever
and yet nothing that they ever say or do
is nearly as harsh as what you judge
yourself as
nobody ever judges you as harshly as you
do yourself
and it's kind of
kind of hard to face the fact hey look
i'm a sex offender i'm molested a child
that's it's a really hard hard portrait
of yourself to look at
and until you get to that point where
you can look at it and
objectively and honestly address it
you're just going to be spinning your
wheels
but once you get to that point once you
really get to a point where you're
i i don't want to do this this isn't
right i can't do this
um you can figure your way through it
but you got to get to that point
excellent well bill thank you so much
for talking with me my pleasure i'm
happy i'm happy for you
30 years that's great thank you
my mother sexually abused us and a baby